(eraser squeaking)
- And that's a Sharpie.
(Raphael laughs)
- What is my favorite animal gag
from the whole six seasons of the show?
It's impossible to pick one.
One that comes to mind which is actually
written in the script
that I think about a lot
'cause I'm very proud of it was,
there's an episode where
a ferret is talking
to Henry Winkler at a funeral
and being very inappropriate
for the funeral,
and Henry Winkler kind of shuts her down
and says, "I'll let you
get back to your business."
and gestures to a group of other ferrets,
and a group of ferrets is called
a business of ferrets.
That is a joke that delights me,
'cause I think it's something
you might not notice
on first watch if you don't happen
to (laughs) possess that piece of trivia.
- Mostly I just sit around the house
and complain about things.
- Yeah, and how's that
working out for you?
- Meh, I can't complain, so.
- It first started because I was friends
with Lisa Hanawalt who
is a brilliant artist.
We went to high school together,
and we would joke about you know one day
we're gonna make a cartoon together
and we had various terrible ideas
but I always had wanted to work
with her on stuff and then she went
to UCLA and I went to
New York for college,
but we stayed in touch.
And then we kind of switched places,
she moved to New York and
then I moved down to L.A.,
and I started pitching shows.
You do a lot of meetings here in Hollywood
and it's like, "Oh, you got any ideas?"
Yeah, I got some ideas,
"We'd love to hear them", here they are.
"Okay, well let us know
if you have any ideas.".
I just told you all my
ideas, what happened?
So I came up with like three to five ideas
and I don't always think about
what direction my life would take
if we'd gone with one of the other ideas
instead of BoJack Horseman.
So I wanted to do a family comedy set
during the Reign of Terror in France,
where the dad was a guillotine salesman,
and business was booming,
but he couldn't get
his wacky family in order.
So that was one idea I had (laughs)
and it was gonna become like
"All in the Family" but like, in France.
And his kids were gonna
be revolutionaries,
and like the ghost of Marie Antoinnette
was gonna be living in their attic.
I think it was gonna be called
"The Good Times are Killing Me."
I think that was the idea,
because it's the guillotines or, you know,
selling like hot cakes and eventually
I ran out of ideas, so what else can I do?
What else can I come up with?
And so I went to Lisa's blog and I pulled
a bunch of her drawings that she had made
because she had been drawing
these animal people on her own
and I thought,
"Okay, what can I do with these?"
But at the same time I
had just moved to L.A.
And I was living in this house
up in the Hollywood hills that was like
a friend of a friend of a friend's house
I somehow was paying
like 800 dollars a month
to live in this glorified closet
in a beautiful mansion,
and I don't quite know
how it was arranged,
but I remember the rumors
amongst the housemates
that it was the third
highest elevated house
in all of Hollywood, that Johnny
Depp had lived there once.
There were all sorts of
secrets in the houses.
It was on the top of this
hill, up this very windy road
that I immediately got
into a car accident on
and then I didn't have a car
and I was stranded up on this house
and I remember looking out
on the deck over all of Hollywood
and feeling simultaneously
on top of the world
and nevermore isolated and alone.
I didn't have any friends,
I didn't know anybody and
so that was the beginning
of the character for me, the idea of this
guy who was living in a house like this
who'd had every opportunity for success
but still couldn't find a way to be happy.
So it's kind of that
married with Lisa's style
is where the show came together
- The show was never the same after I left
admit it.
- Some people prefer the later years.
- The character of BoJack was not written
with Will in mind, I think he might be
delighted to know
(laughs)
I wasn't thinking you
know who'd be a great
washed up, sad, lonely actor?
Will Arnett
(laughs)
No, it was written just as for BoJack
It was written for this drawing that
Lisa Hanawalt had drawn of this horse guy
and then once we were
developing the project
we thought you know before
we pitch this around
It might help to have some talent attached
So Linda Lamontagne was
our casting director
she kind of drew up a
list of here are some
actors I think would be right for this
and as soon as I saw Will Arnett's name
I was like, oh my God, yes, that's the guy
because he's so funny,
but there's also a darkness to him
and I feel like in his gravely performance
you feel like he's lived a life
and there's like a sadness
lurking underneath there,
but again, he's so funny.
I mean there are lines
that we have made BoJack
say that I would
not have the hutspa to give to an actor
because they're so dopey
but that I knew that Will
Arnett could pull them off.
Like, I remember in the writer's room
like looking at line of scripting
like, are we gonna keep this
line and this is so stupid
and then we do the table read
and Will Arnett reads
it and it's the funniest
thing you've ever heard.
(laughs)
Oh my God, he took our dumbest stuff
and he spun it into gold,
and that's what you
want (laughs) on a show
you want someone who elevates the material
and I am so blessed with our cast
that just every single one of them
elevates the material,
every single one of them is better
than the jokes you give them.
Like, you can give them set ups to jokes
and they make the set ups funny.
You can give them sad lines
and they make them tragic,
you can give them sad lines,
they make them tragic and funny
at the same time somehow,
one of the funniest things I've ever heard
was Will Arnett going, "what?"
What?
The line was "What"?
And he kills it.
- You're a good sport.
- (groans) You know who that is?
- Mr. Peanutbutter?
- Paul's also hilarious,
I mean Paul's an
incredibly talented actor,
his instincts are dead on,
and also, I think he preps.
I think he looks at the script beforehand
and makes choices and thinks,
"How am I gonna do this line,?
"what is the funniest way to do this?"
So he comes in and he's just
overflowing with funny ideas.
You know, when I was first
writing the character
of Mr. Peanutbutter,
I initially heard him in my head as like
more of like a meathead, more
of a deep kind of gravely,
like a Patrick Warburton type, you know
you can kind of imagine the big lank head
but because we cast Will,
who has this deep voice
and then we cast Aaron as Todd
and Aaron also has a pretty deep voice
I felt like if we have a
third deep voice guy (laughs)
it's just gonna get repetitive and boring
and so I wanted someone
who had a higher register
and I thought Paul had
this beautiful (mumbles)
quality to him, it almost feels like he's
skipping across the line
which I think as a foil
to BoJack is very funny,
that BoJack even in his
voice he is very kind of
sunk down and in the muck,
whereas Mr. Peanutbutter
is playfully skipping
above the muck.
- I'm responsible for my own happiness?
I can't even be responsible
for my own breakfast.
- I pitched it as a show
that is gonna start very fun
and goofy like most adult animated shows,
but by the end of its first season
it's gonna turn into more of a dramady
along lines of a live action show
like a Girl's or even Madman, I think were
the examples I used at the time
which felt a little more unprecedented
in the world of animation
to indulge that much
in seriousness and emotion,
but that was the idea
that we were gonna trick
people by making people think
it was a typical animated sitcom
but actually by the end of the season
they'd be going "Oh my god,
why do I have feelings?"
"Where did this come from?"
I think in my plan, I always assumed
the audience will join us on this ride
and go from "Oh this
is fun, this is silly"
to "Oh my god, I have feelings"
It never occurred to me that some people
might see the silly part and go
"Not for me", click, and not even know
that the rest of this show turns into
this totally other thing.
I think if I were doing it again,
I might try to include
more clues at the beginning
that this was a more serious show,
but even then I think it's hard to do
because there are clues in the beginning
and I think because of the context of
it being an adult animated show
people didn't see those clues because
they assumed they knew what it was, right?
And so they saw the clues that
affirmed what they thought
it was, but they missed the stuff
that didn't point in that direction.
In the first episode of the show
BoJack and Dianne have like
a two minute conversation
on the fleeting nature
of happiness, right?
So that should be a hint
that, like "oh that's what the
"show is really interested in,"
but I remember reading
reviews of the first season
and one said you know
"for a show that is meant
"to be just wall-to-wall jokes, there sure
"are a lot of scenes that don't have
"that many jokes"
and I thought, you're so close,
your first instinct is what is this like
that I've seen before,
and I think what I try to
do is make it kind of like
what people had seen before
but also have one foot
in something kind of new and challenging,
and I think if I were doing it again,
I wouldn't spend as much
time in the what audiences
have seen before.
I don't think they needed their hands held
as much as I thought they did.
I think audiences were
ready for something new
and something different,
because that's the thing
that everybody loved
about the first season.
Is that it did that change
and then it was both
of those things, that it wasn't just one
or the other and so, when we were working
on season two,
I definitely felt the confidence
of like let's go further
in that direction because
that's what the show is,
that's the sweet spot, that's what people
are interested in, is this emotional stuff
while at the same time is a goofy, silly,
fun cartoon.
(cheerful music)
Where did the theme song come from?
That's a great question,
so Andy Gowan is our music supervisor
and he kind of put the word out
to a bunch of different bands
and a bunch of different artists,
"Hey, here's a new show,
"we're looking for some music"
And we got a lot of responses,
and the two that kind of
rose to the top for me
was this very playful
sing-songy group love song
and this very heavy,
spooky, Patrick Carney
and Ralph Carney song,
and I remember there was a lot of debate
over which song are we gonna use,
and then we put together
this main title sequence.
The director Mike Roberts
puts together this incredible
sequence of Bojack kind
of going through his day
and we played different songs over it
to see what felt right,
and we'd bring in people from the crew,
we did focus groups
and it like was pretty evenly split,
like people loved the group love song
and people loved the Patrick
Carney-Ralph Carney song,
and at the end of the day we thought,
can we do both?
(laughs)
and so we ended up
using the Patrick Carney
Ralph Carney song in the beginning
and the group love song at the end
I think they do different things
in really fun ways and I really like
that the Carney song has more of a spooky,
melancholy feel to it,
I think it is a little bit of a hint
of what's to come in this show,
it does make you think like,
"Oh this feels a little more dramatic
"than a like typical animated fun sitcom"
and then I think the group love song
kind of the opposite is so fun and bright
and at the end of some of our episodes
which are really downer
endings, like it almost
feels like an ironic like
you know poke in the ribs.
Like, it's almost taunting
and it almost brings out
the emotionality in a fun
new way that is also darkly humorous,
and so I really enjoyed using that song
as juxtaposition against
all these different
endings.
Especially as the show has
gotten more and more serious,
it's kind of revealed itself
to have new layers to it.
- [Singer] I was in a very famous TV show.
(upbeat music)